Off 1.
Jessica, Présidente-Directrice Générale
d’une grande firme multinationale, va bientôt
partir à la retraite.
Son entreprise est sa vie.
C’est son bébé et elle veut la voir continuer
à grandir.
Mais surtout, elle ne veut pas l’abandonner
à n’importe qui.
Malheureusement, le conseil d’administration
semble souhaiter voir un certain Daniel lui
succéder.
Jessica déteste Daniel.
Et elle détesterait voir Daniel prendre contrôle
de sa compagnie.
Sauf que le conseil d’administration le
sait.
Du coup, Jessica ne pourra pas les influencer
comme elle l’aimerait.
Désespérée, elle se tourne vers un mathématicien.
Off 2.
Le mathématicien demande à Jessica de lui
faire un topo sur les candidats potentiels.
Jessica dresse une liste de 5 candidats.
On y trouve bien sûr Daniel, mais aussi Harvey,
Louis, Rachel et Mike.
Jessica est persuadée que Harvey en particulier
est un candidat prometteur, et que le conseil
d’administration le sait.
Elle est persuadée que Harvey mérite d’être
le prochain PDG de son entreprise.
Mais le mathématicien n’est pas convaincu.
Il doit en savoir plus.
Que pensent les différents membres du conseil
d’administration ?
Off 3.
Jessica affirme que le conseil d’administration
est composé de 5 membres importants de qui
va dépendre l’issue du vote du prochain
PDG.
Ces membres sont Francis, Doug, Peter, Claire
et Jessica elle-même.
Jessica les connaît bien.
Elle est même quasi-certaine des préférences
des membres du conseil d’administration.
D'après elle,
Francis préfère Daniel à Rachel à Harvey
à Mike à Louis.
Doug préfère Daniel à Louis à Mike à
Harvey à Rachel.
Peter préfère Louis à Daniel à Mike à
Claire préfère Rachel à Louis à Mike à
Harvey à Daniel.
Enfin, Jessica préfère Harvey à Rachel
à Mike à Louis à Daniel.
Jessica se tourne vers notre mathématicien,
et lui demande : que pouvez-vous faire pour
empêcher l’élection de ce salaud de Daniel
qui n’a cessé de vouloir me voler mon entreprise
?
Le mathématicien, très intrigué, rentre
chez lui et, armé de sa familiarité avec
la théorie mathématique des scrutins, il
se met à tester diverses combinaisons.
Off 4.
Pour un scrutin à un tour, Daniel recevrait
deux voix et serait élu par 2 voix, contre
1 voix pour Louis, 1 pour Rachel et 1 pour
Harvey.
À moins que Claire et Jessica ne s’allie
pour faire élire Rachel.
Non, ça ne suffirait pas parce que Peter
pourra faire pencher la balance du côté
de Daniel.
Et du coup, Daniel serait quand même élu.
Off 4.
Et si on faisait une élection en 2 tours
? On pourrait alors avoir un duel Rachel contre
Daniel au second tour…
Mais non, ça ne marcherait pas non plus.
C’est encore Daniel qui l’emporterait…
À moins que l’on n’arrive à convaincre
Claire de voter Louis.
Mais oui, ça, ça marcherait…
Mais ça serait galère.
Il faudrait imposer un système à 2 tours
et convaincre Claire de voter Louis…
Off 4.
Et si l’on disait à chaque membre de voter
leur ordre de préférence, en attribuant
ensuite 4 points au premier choix, 3 points
au second choix, 2 points au troisième choix,
1 point au 4è et 0 au dernier ? Daniel aurait
alors 4+4+3+0+0=11 points.
Rachel en aurait 3+0+0+4+3=10 points.
Harvey 2+1+1+1+4=9, Mike 1+2+2+2+2=9 et Louis
0+3+4+3+1=11 points.
On aurait alors une égalité entre Daniel
et Louis…
Mais Jessica pourrait mettre Louis en premier
de ses préférences, et Louis serait alors
élu ! Bingo ! Sauf que… sauf que ce vote
par préférences et ce système de points,
ça a l’air trop compliqué à imposer.
Off 4.
En tout cas, toutes ces analyses semblent
indiquer que Louis est la clé de la solution.
Jessica ne va pas aimer ça…
Elle n’a pas l’air d’aimer Louis beaucoup
plus que Daniel…
Ça sent pas bon…
À moins que…
Off 4.
Et si on faisait un système par agenda, comme
pour les tournois sportifs.
On fait des matchs qui opposent deux candidats.
Le perdant est éliminé, et on continue ainsi
jusqu’à ce qu’il ne reste plus qu’un
candidat !
Off 4.
On peut ainsi tester Daniel vs Louis, Harvey
vs Mike, puis le vainqueur de Daniel vs Louis
jouera contre Rachel, et on finit avec une
finale entre les deux restants.
Daniel vs Louis, c’est Louis qui gagne.
Harvey vs Mike, c’est Mike qui gagne.
Louis vs Rachel, c’est Rachel qui gagne.
Du coup, on se retrouve avec une finale Rachel
vs Mike.
Et bingo, c’est Mike qui gagne ! Sauf que…
Off 4.
Sauf que ce tableau des matchs est un peu
arbitraire.
Comment Jessica pourra-t-elle convaincre le
conseil d’administration de l’utiliser
?
Je sais !
Off 4.
On va utiliser un agenda plus naturel.
On va commencer à opposer les deux grands
favoris, Daniel et Louis.
Et comme ça, on élimine tout de suite Daniel.
Puis on pourrait faire Mike vs Louis.
Ça, c’est Louis qui gagne.
Puis Louis contre Rachel, et ça ça ferait
gagner Rachel.
Et enfin, Rachel versus Harvey…
Et bingo, c’est Harvey qui gagne ! Et ça,
ça c’est robuste et ça va plaire à Jessica
!
Off 5.
Le lendemain, au moment de passer au vote
du futur PDG, Jessica annonce, d’un air
confiant, que tout le monde sait que ça va
se jouer entre Daniel et Louis, et propose
donc de voter à main levée entre les deux.
Les membres du conseil, pour qui Daniel ou
Louis est l’un des deux préférés, sont
tous d’accord.
À main levée, c’est Louis qui l’emporte.
Jessica annonce du coup que Louis est le nouveau
PDG.
Off 5.
C’est alors que Francis, qui déteste Louis,
rajoute qu’il y a tout de même d’autres
candidats et qu’il ne serait pas sérieux
de ne pas les prendre en compte.
Que pensez-vous de Mike,
Off 5. lance tout à coup Jessica.
Le vote entre Louis et Mike est effectué,
et Mike perd.
Jessica se tourne vers Francis, et lui demande
du coup :
« une autre suggestion ? »
Off 5.
Francis rétorque :
oui, Rachel bien sûr.
Off 5.
Le vote entre Rachel et Louis tourne maintenant
à l’avantage de Rachel, qui est maintenant
la nouvelle futur PDG !
Off 5.
Mais c’est au tout de Peter et Doug de s’indigner.
Peter et Doug, d'un air macho, affirment que
Rachel n’a pas les épaules pour tenir l’entreprise.
Peter et Doug, dos au mur, suggèrent alors
le nom de Harvey.
Francis réplique :
« Non pas lui »,
Off 5. suivi de Claire qui affirme que Rachel
est largement assez compétente et que Peter
et Doug font preuve là de sexisme.
Le conseil d’administration devient alors
bruyant et désorganisé.
Jessica, feignant d’être à bout de nerfs,
exige alors le silence et cède aux indignations
de Peter et Doug.
Mais elle rajoute, énervée, qu’il s’agira
là du dernier vote.
Le conseil d’administration passe alors
au vote entre Rachel et Harvey.
Et c’est Harvey qui gagne !
Off 5.
Jessica l’annonce alors officiellement,
d’une voix neutre qui ne laisse pas transparaître
le triomphalisme qu’elle ressent intérieurement
: « Harvey sera donc mon successeur.
Il sera le prochain PDG de notre entreprise.
Félicitations à lui.
»
Et le plus fou dans cette histoire, c’est
que le conseil d'administration croît que
l’élection de Harvey est parfaitement légitime.
En particulier, personne n’a imaginé que
le choix du nouveau PDG a été entièrement
façonné bien avant la réunion du conseil
d’administration, par la main invisible
d’un mathématicien malveillant.
Alors, on pourrait croire que l’histoire
de Jessica et Harvey que j’ai raconté là,
tout comme les séries télés House of Cards
et Suits,
Oui le nom et les photos des personnages viennent
de ces séries, pour ceux qui ne connaissent
pas.
on pourrait croire que tout ce que j’ai
raconté là n’est que fiction…
Et bien non ! Ce que je vous ai raconté là
est inspiré du livre {\it Prédictions: How
to See and Shape the Future with Game Theory}
de Bruce Bueno de Mesquita, un chercheur en
théorie des jeux qui vend notamment ses prédictions
géopolitiques aux agences de sécurité et
fait mieux que les avis des experts.
Mesquita y parle de la fois où un PDG bientôt
à la retraite l’avait embauché pour faire
tourner la balance dans l’élection de son
successeur.
Et On reparlera bien plus longuement du livre
de Mesquite dans cette série sur la démocratie.
Ce que je veux que vous reteniez de cette
vidéo, c’est que le processus électoral
affecte grandement l’issue d’un vote.
Et ceci transcende de loin le problème de
la politique.
En fait, ce dont j’essaierai de vous convaincre
dans les prochaines vidéos, c’est que l’on
peut grandement influencer le futur de nos
sociétés en choisissant les scrutins que
l’on veut mettre en place.
Pire encore, les scrutins que nous utilisons
aujourd’hui ont des conséquences extrêmement
néfastes sur notre manière de réfléchir
et de penser non seulement la politique, mais
aussi divers sujets de société.
Dans la prochaine vidéo, j’essaierai de
vous convaincre que les scrutins à 1 tour
et à 2 tours nous poussent à nous diviser,
et favorisent ainsi le concept d’opposition
politique et de votes protestataires.
Or, cette notion de convictions contestataires,
c’est, il me semble, l’une des sources
majeurs des montées des pseudo-sciences et
des idéologies extrémistes.
Et dans les vidéos qui suivent, je vous présenterai
diverses alternatives à cela, mais j’irai
aussi plus loin dans l’intrication entre
la théorie mathématique des jeux et divers
phénomènes de sociétés…
L’objectif final sera de vous montrer comment
les mathématiques appliquées ont grandement
chamboulé ma compréhension de nos sociétés,
et comment elles peuvent permettre de mieux
penser ce qu’il faut faire ou ne pas faire
pour annoncer des lendemains meilleurs…